today on the matt well show in the
lead-up to the ncaa women's swimming
championships where a man named leah
thomas is expected to dominate and break
records sports illustrated has run a
fawning cover story hailing his courage
and athletic prowess i have a few
thoughts to offer on that and also an
announcement that you're going to want
to hear that's coming up stick around
for that also the leftist meltdown at
university of north texas was even worse
than we thought more video and
information has emerged we'll talk about
it plus some lawmakers in dc seem dead
sets on getting us involved in a world
war and some of them also desecrated an
american flag to prove their loyalty to
ukraine so we'll talk about that as well
and in some churches across the country
ash wednesday has apparently been
replaced with glitter ash wednesday what
is that and is it as heretical as it
sounds we'll talk about all that more
today on the matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know if you've been listening to my
show for a while you know that i'm an
activist against the lazy grocery
shoppers who don't put the grocery carts
away uh while i have some some tragic
news the grocery carts i guess had their
revenge and attacked me in my own car
unfortunately when i was pulling out of
my parking spot a rogue grocery cart
left there by some
terrorist crashed into my car leaving my
front bumper scratched now there are two
lessons we can take from this one don't
be lazy put your shopping carts away so
i don't have to suffer and two you can
solve an issue like mine really quickly
without breaking the bank by just
visiting rockauto.com rockauto.com is an
online family-owned business that sells
all auto parts that you could ever
possibly need that are specific to your
own vehicle their prices are shockingly
reasonable and their shipping is quick
so no matter what's going on with your
car you can trust rock auto to get you
what you need fast and if you don't know
anything about cars there's no no need
to worry rock auto is a very friendly
user website and uh very user-friendly
website and they make it very easy to
pick the right parts for your specific
car so you can feel confident that
you'll get the right parts for your
vehicle and get them an affordable way
as well so what are you waiting for go
to rockauto.com for your auto part needs
today and write walsh in there how did
you hear about us box they know that i'm
the one that sent you that's
rockauto.com to shop for your auto parts
today
the mainstream sports media spends most
every day trying to convince the public
and themselves that they are more
important than they really are not not
satisfied to just report and analyze
sports they've deluded themselves into
thinking that the world needs to hear
their insights into all the major social
and political issues of the day and
they're mistaken about that this mistake
is why people have increasingly turned
off sports media and sports in general
uh because people just don't want that
but their inflated sense of importance
and their suicidal determination to
inject themselves into every issue
just makes their cowardice all the more
shameful and embarrassing because
there's actually one relevant social
issue where the voices of the sports
world are needed there is at least one
supposedly controversial topic that they
should be speaking about
they should be filling their airwaves
with and that's exactly the one that
most of them refuse to discuss
the one social issue that crosses over
into their alleged area of interest and
expertise is precisely the one that
they're not going to touch with a 10
foot pole
or else even worse
they do acknowledge it but only to bow
in submission to the woke mob
the issue of course that we're talking
about is the destruction of women's
sports through the intrusion and
sabotage of biological males
and when it comes to the latter option
of bowing in submission
sports illustrated i think wins the gold
for the most shameful and obsequious
display we've seen yet
yesterday sports illustrated published
its big cover story written by robert
sanchez titled i am leah the trans
swimmer dividing america tells her story
now the article could have been written
by thomas's publicist and i'm sure he
has one and it probably was basically
written by a publicist
but um to begin there's a short video
kind of setting the stage and we'll uh
we'll watch some of that
leah thomas is the most controversial
athlete in america today
the university of pennsylvania swimmer
has set pool school and ivy league
records this season and route to
becoming the nation's most dominant
female collegiate swimmer
she also is a trans woman who has faced
bigotry and criticism from those who
don't think she should be allowed to
swim with or against female competition
the issue reached its peak this swim
season as thomas put herself on track to
dominate the ncaa championships this
month in atlanta georgia in addition to
being a favorite in the 200 yard and 500
yard freestyle events she also could
break long-standing ncaa records held by
olympic stars katie ledecky and missy
franklin
it's hardly been an easy road for thomas
who began hormone replacement therapy in
may 2019 after years of gender dysphoria
the shy quiet swimmer from austin texas
began feeling relief almost immediately
after beginning her treatments
she took the 2020-2021 academic year off
to ensure she would be able to swim as a
member of the penn women's team
and as her authentic self
this swim season thomas has faced
criticisms even from within her own team
they say her previous puberty gives her
an advantage over her competition that
she's denigrating women's sports that
she has treated her competition as a
joke
but she insists she isn't thinking about
records she says she simply wants to
race against women
she wants to swim as leah thomas
now notice once again how thomas is
labeled uh not only a woman athlete but
also female
because the sex and gender distinction
proves itself to be prove proves itself
to be as always a sleight of hand trick
we're expected to see thomas as not only
a self-identified woman
his gender allegedly but also as a
biological female
and this male female is about to topple
female college records are we allowed to
have a problem with that no as sports
sports illustrated makes abundantly
clear the puff piece begins by
establishing leah thomas as a shy and
unassuming college student somehow
caught up in a controversy
not at all of his own making of course
here's what it says quote
first off
fresh off her final practice of the week
the most controversial athlete in
america sat in the corner of a nearly
empty philadelphia coffee house with her
back to the wall leah thomas had done
some of her best work this season while
feeling cornered on this january evening
her long torso was wrapped in a
university of pennsylvania swim and dive
jacket her hair still damp from a swim
roughly three miles staring at the black
line on the bottom of the pool
she looked exhausted as college students
across the country were digging into
their friday nights thomas was thinking
about her weekend plans sleeping
studying another grueling swim practice
this has been a season unlike any in her
22 years and unlike any in the history
of her sport the shy senior economics
major from austin became one of the most
dominant college athletes in the country
and as a result the center of a national
debate a living breathing real-time
rorschach test for how society views
those who challenge conventions
right well that's
yeah that's why he became controversial
is because he was dominant
but how did that happen i mean how did
this shy student
become a dominant college athlete
prior to this past year he was ranked i
think in the 400s mediocre on his best
day
so how did that happen well in his
fourth year at school he grew his hair
out and became a woman presto chango
just like that continuing it says um
quoting now from leah thomas i'm a woman
just like anybody else on the team
thomas says i've always viewed myself as
just a swimmer it's what i've done for
so long it's what i love
she's not thinking about wins or records
she insists i get into the water every
day and do my best
being trans thomas says is an amazing
and beautiful experience i've been
reinvigorated
i've been swimming for 17 years but for
only a short part of that time have i
felt fully engaged
she's forever grateful for the kindness
people closest to her showed during such
a stressful time she says she continues
to appreciate the support of those
people how that love gives her hope for
the life she'll someday make for herself
quote after coming out and being my
authentic self i could really start to
see a future she says before i came out
i couldn't visualize a future
now of course
the article presents thomas as not only
a courageous female athlete but a martyr
as well we're told all about the the
hate mail and angry comments thomas has
received
all of this is chalked up to bigotry
though if it's bigotry against anything
it's against cheaters
and it seems by the way nearly certain
that the writer of this article
robert sanchez
knows that this is all nonsense because
there's just no way that anyone
has actually been convinced by the
arguments in favor of allowing males and
female sports because there are no
arguments in favor of it
the emperor has no clothes or in this
case the the emperor is a dude in
women's clothes and everybody can see it
but few will speak out against it and
next thomas will go to georgia tech for
the ncaa women's swimming championships
steal medals and records
and we already know that an audience
there in the uh watching will applaud
dutifully even though they know that
it's all a joke
and it's sickening
and that's why i will be showing up to
georgia tech also on march 14th um the
same week as the championships i'll be
holding an event on campus
to explain why men don't belong in
women's sports and why leah thomas is
personally and specifically a cheater
now thomas may be confused about his
gender
um but he still knows what he's doing
he is choosing to put his own feelings
and desires and self-esteem above every
woman on his team and every other team
you notice in in all in this whole
article all the me's and i it's all
about him
the other people on his team they don't
even factor into the equation
he's not worried about them at all
because he's an entitled narcissist and
he deserves all the condemnation that he
gets
and in fact he should be getting a lot
more of it so i'll deliver some of that
on march 14th one other note about this
after i announced this event yesterday
um i was greeted with
some familiar criticism
you know the critic critics ask well why
am i getting involved in this issue why
am i pretending to care about women's
sports
you know is anyone supposed to believe
that i actually care about women's
sports this much
well i'll answer that question i've been
quite clear that my primary concern is
not women's sports itself
never pretended that it was
i don't watch women's sports and no
prior to men intruding into it i didn't
care that much about it
but i do care about the truth
and women's sports has become
not because i want it to be
but because the trans agenda made it so
an important battleground in the war for
truth
i also care about justice
and it's not just it's not fair
for women to be treated this way
to be deprived of victories that they've
rightfully earned it's not fair it's not
just
that's why i care
but even so
should i be the one holding this event
i mean should i be one of the loudest
voices about this issue
should i be one of the one of the
loudest people defending women's sports
no i shouldn't
it would be best if some prominent
athlete were to show up and stage this
protest michael phelps should be there
speaking now think about how powerful
that would be
that'd be that'd be much better if
michael phelps volunteered i would say
oh forget my event i'll go to his
or maybe one of those female olympians
whose records are about to be broken by
a man maybe one of them
think about how powerful they that would
be if one of them showed up
on campus the same week
and held an event calling this out
calling it what it is which is cheating
that would be great
there's and again if someone were to do
that i would say forget my event i'll
everyone go i'll go and attend it myself
i'll attend this one
there's a whole list of people who would
be more powerful voices on this than me
the problem is they're not saying
anything
they're silent they're staying as far
away from this as they can
and so i have to go
if you don't like it don't blame me
blame the cowards who should be standing
up there but aren't
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
okay so uh another
campus that i want to um
that i'd like to make an appearance on
we're trying still trying to trying to
set it up if we can is university of
north texas and we talked about that
yesterday to start the show
the total
satanic meltdown that ensued at
university of north texas
um
because somebody showed up on campus and
uh gave a talk about why
children should not be castrated um why
it's you know why we shouldn't be
butchering gender confused children and
it just so happens that the guy that was
giving the talk jeff younger
is a father who's who has been trying to
rescue his own son
from
this barbarity
and but has been has been prevented from
doing that by the courts who have given
uh custody over to the mom because the
mom is gender affirming
which is to say the mom is going to go
along with her kid being being um
abused and mutilated
and this was enough for the for the
people on campus to for the kids on
campus and the lgbt activists to lose
their mind i mean it really did watching
some of the footage and we played some
of it yesterday i have another clip
we'll play again we'll play here
but watching the footage it really does
remind you as i'm so often reminded
when i see these kinds of temper
tantrums from the left um it does kind
of harken back to to the exorcist it's
like this
demonic you almost expect to see their
heads turning around 360 degrees
start vomiting green slime all over the
place levitating like you expect to see
that
because they're just filled with satanic
rage
at the idea that anybody would try to
protect kids from being butchered
so before we have an update here from
the daily wire
here's one clip we didn't play yesterday
um
and this is one when it comes to liberal
meltdowns i think this is one that will
that will live in infamy this is almost
as good you know the the the most famous
liberal meltdown of course is that right
after trump was elected in dc the the
infamous footage of the woman falling to
her knees and shouting no up into the
sky um this is almost as good as that
watch this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
i don't know what else can you do but
laugh
you know you see that it's easy enough
to see that and think well look mental
illness is a real problem in this
country
and uh clearly this is someone who's
mentally deranged
and and
yes that's that's true i'm not denying
that
um these are not mentally stable people
but
we have to realize that the the mental
illness um is not you know they they
weren't born with it
um this is something that has been
they've been conditioned into it it's
been implanted in their minds
and through the the conditioning through
the you know the gender theory gender
ideology conditioning
but also through through this sense of
entitlement
that they've been
you know conditioned into that they've
that they've grown up with
they they've
these kids have been coddled to such an
extent
that for even one person
to say something they disagree with it
isn't it
they can't handle it they don't know how
to handle it
they don't know how to handle someone
disagreeing with them
what they could have done i mean that
whole room
was full of people on the other side of
it it was full of people who disagree
with jeff younger
so what they could have done
is just
not showed up
and gone about their lives
and from the looks of it you know jeff
younger would have been talking to an
empty room mostly
but to eat the knowledge to to know
that there is someone in their vicinity
saying things
expressing views that are not their own
just the the knowledge of that they
they they can't handle it
they're compelled to show up and they
don't have any arguments to present
obviously all they can do is just scream
in infantile rage
at the idea that
anyone is allowed to disagree with them
and as i said yesterday you know we like
to comfort ourselves on the right we've
been comforting ourselves far too often
speaking of being coddled we've kind of
tried to coddle ourselves a little bit
and comfort ourselves by by saying that
uh you know
these kids they'll
they're in for a for a rude awakening
when they you know go out into the world
and um they're going to encounter the
real world and they're going to they're
going to get over this pretty quickly
that's not the case
unfortunately
because they're going out into a world
that they are also shaping
i mean
this is the next generation they're
they're taking over
and so that sense of entitlement all of
it
it's it's not going anywhere
it's just going to metastasize
maybe for some of them i hope there will
be there will be an awakening of sorts
but it's not going to be a necessary
awakening there's nothing about the
quote real world right now
that would require them
to um awake from the stupor
from this self-centered narcissistic
stupor
in fact our entire culture is designed
now
to continue to coddle these people
that's a scary thought
it's a scary thought for a lot of
reasons one of them is that um
you know those the kids are not in that
room there
if somebody had just gone up and shot
jeff younger in the head how do you
think the kids would have responded
you think they would have been upset to
see that
no that kind of rage it's because they
want you dead i mean they think that you
should be dead and and oftentimes
they're quite clear about that
they think that you should be dead for
disagreeing with them
that's how they they think that's what
they believe and they are taking that
belief with them into the greater into
the outside world
all right um
speaking of voice this is from the daily
wire it says black cat black-clad
protesters screamed and heckled at a
college student and jeff younger the
father of a child the center of national
disputes over transgenderism um
forcing police to rush the student and
younger to safety so this is the part
that we we didn't actually see in the
clip that we played we had them
screaming they were spitting and
everything um and then at some point
apparently the police intervene
and um this is the exclusive report from
the daily wire it says reportedly
spurred on by anger over texas's new
transgender directive which we know
about um
at least 70 black-clad protesters
milled into the young conservatives of
texas wednesday evening event at the
university of north texas
during the event police suddenly entered
the room and ordered student kelly
nydert who was one of the people up
there on on
you know in front of the crowd trying to
present her case
um
and also younger to evacuate the student
described tense moments following the
evacuation in which she hid in a
janitor's closet with a policeman as
screaming protesters ran through the
halls of the building searching for her
neighbor younger who is the father of
james younger
say that uh so the members of the
university of north texas police
department the texas department of
public safety and the denton police
department were present on wednesday
night none of these organizations
responded to the daily wires request for
comments um
and so the niner talks about hiding in
this closet
as there are
these black clad call them protesters
but this is something more than that
patrolling the hallways searching for
her
what were they gonna do if they found
her
remember what i said they want you dead
they really do
she told the lyre quote initially when
we were first led out of the building to
evacuate i felt like everything was
going to be under control but after i
was chased into the building with a
police officer when we were in this
janitor's closet i honestly was very
scared
[Music]
for good reason
this stuff has never really seemed scary
to me i guess i don't really care about
the backlash i received but when i was
literally hiding in a janitor's closet
with a police officer and the lights off
with these people running in the hallway
screaming
i mean at this point i was pretty scared
for my life
yeah
for for good reason
you know these
the lawmakers on january 6th
we're supposed to feel
a great amount of sympathy for them i
mean they're all martyrs they're
survivors
none of them have a tail as harrowing as
this
and she was also totally outnumbered
um
and they're patrolling the hallways
looking for again what were they gonna
do if they found her
you know they want you dead for
disagreeing with them
but the other thing is they've been told
repeatedly and this is part of the
conditioning they've been told
that
you know opposing viewpoints are violent
are a threat to their very existence
we hear this all the time
and this is especially true when it
comes to anything related to lgbt trans
if you're at all critical of the trans
agenda then you are your viewpoints are
a threat
to the very existence of trans people
and these kids have been told that their
whole lives
now they've never stopped to think about
it they've never stopped and actually
asked themselves well how is my
existence threatened because this guy
disagrees with me
they just believe it
and that alone justifies violence
they could go and kill you and say well
self-defense you were threatening my
existence
that's how the stage is being said and
very intentionally so
all right um let's move over to this
nancy pelosi uh sent out a tweet a
couple days ago that didn't
attract a lot of attention when she
first posted it but we'll put this up
says the congress remains unwavering and
resolute in our support for the people
of ukraine
we are committed to providing
humanitarian and security assistance to
ukraine as russia wages unprovoked and
premeditated war
um
so okay that's pretty standard
talking points there but then you zoom
in and you see all the lawmakers
uh you know
dozens of them anyway standing on the
steps of the capitol and they're holding
a flag and then yeah you get to zoom in
and you see there it is a an american
flag and a ukrainian flag which has been
combined
and so part of the
american flag has been colored you know
yellow and blue and adorned with
ukrainian symbols
in other words the flag has been
desecrated
so we are now at the point where we are
desecrating the american flag to own
putin
that's that's what that is that's that's
the desecration of the flag
and all these smiling and you see dan
crenshaw he's there smiling along
what is this supposed to prove exactly
the day before this they were taking
their american flags off
to go to the state of the union
putting on the ukrainian lapels
and now they're desecrating a flag an
american flag
this this is this is all part of the
this is all part of the the hype and the
the war fever
which is only getting worse by the way
because desecrating the flag is pretty
bad
that's a pretty bad tweet
not as bad as this though this is uh
lindsey graham yesterday tweeted this
and i think he also went on sean hannity
and and uh made this case so he's very
he's very proud of this this wasn't
something that he said in the heat of
the moment or something and regret
saying now
um he put this out there he says is
there a brutus in russia is there a more
successful colonel stoffenberg in the
russian military the only way this ends
is for somebody in russia to take this
guy out meaning putin of course
you would be doing your country and the
world a great service
okay so
no big deal there
just one of our most prominent elected
officials
openly and publicly calling for the
assassination
of the leader of
a a nuclear-armed country
now there are two
issues here okay
the first is that
assassinating putin would actually
probably be a terrible idea because then
you end up with a power vacuum
you end up with a power vacuum
in this again nuclear-armed superpower
country
and who who who steps in there who takes
his place
someone's going in
whoever however whoever steps in and
sees his power are they likely to be
uh more pro-america and pro-west
after we've just called for the
assassination of of of of putin
i mean we've seen this play out over the
last many decades
that when we create power vacuums
somebody steps into it
and most of the time it's somebody worse
yeah we saw that in
we've seen that in the middle east and
and
it's hard for me to see
especially right now of all times
how creating that kind of instability
destabilizing russia it's hard for me to
see how that makes the world safer
but even if it did
like
even if you could argue
that taking putin out would be the best
move
you don't say it publicly you don't
tweet it out what's that supposed to
accomplish
all that does is i mean the the people
of russia from as far as we can tell not
that we're getting a lot of you know
this is not information that russia's
eager to publicize but from what we've
seen
this war is not popular in russia
you know the very first day that it
broke out uh there were mass
demonstrations in russia against it
so the people are
largely on our side when it comes to
this war anyway
if you're trying to think of ways to
turn them against us and and have them
rally around putin
i think calling for the assassination of
their political leaders is probably the
way to do it
so whether or not it would be a good
idea and would be for the best for putin
to be taken out which i don't think it
would be for the best
certainly saying it out loud is not the
way to do it
is that also isn't that i'm pretty sure
that's a violation of uh
this is lower on the list of priorities
here but isn't that also a violation of
twitter's terms of service
you you can actually call for a person's
assassination on twitter and you're not
violating any any rules there
these are the people we have leading us
i mean for lindsey graham this is um
you know i asked the question why did he
what was the point of of posting that
however you feel about assassinating
putin what's the point of saying it
well the real point is that it's just uh
you know it's it's a way to get
attention it's a it's like a very odd
form of virtue signaling
you can see where we've gotten to in our
culture when uh calling for someone's
assassination is a virtue signal that's
what it is
desecrating the american flag is also a
virtue signal
and so for him it's all it's all just a
joke it's it's nothing
because
if we get into a world war he's not
going to be the one going over there to
fight it
same for adam kinsinger who tweeted this
yesterday he said this is a good moment
to renew my call for a no-fly zone at
the invitation of the ukraine government
oh well they invited us so okay well
that's that's all that matters as long
as they invite us as long as ukraine has
invited us to get it to get ourselves
involved in this and risk american lives
and start a world war if they've invited
us well then we should certainly do it
he says i fear if this continues we will
have to intervene in a bigger way
now a no-fly zone just to be very clear
about this
um
a no-fly zone is an act of war
okay you are
the moment you start shooting at
russian planes or russian um military
that's an act of war so
kinsar is calling for us to get involved
in this war
and i'll tell you i
my position is very simple
i'm i feel sorry for ukraine um i think
it's bad what's happening to them
i wish that it was not happening
i think that what putin is doing is very
wrong to invade the country this way and
and start
shelling the cities and everything i
think that's all wrong
but
i would rather
russia take over ukraine
than see american lives lost in defense
of ukraine
i would rather that
those are two bad outcomes
no question about it
but for me as an american
the worst outcome
is that americans
end up losing their lives by the
thousands or the millions potentially
given that we would be getting involved
in a war with again a nuclear superpower
a country that has six thousand i think
nuclear weapons
all right here's something on uh a guest
on cnn said that i thought was kind of
interesting this is one of those moments
when
you know this is this isn't this isn't
cnn but who can tell the difference
anymore um this is a this is one of
those moments when someone on the left
says something and it provokes i get you
know some outrage and condemnation from
the right but uh but it's honest and i
kind of prefer the honesty so let's
listen to this
now in your book allow me to retort you
reframe politics and the constitution by
kind of breaking down how it all impacts
voting rights like you mentioned lgbtq
rights abortion rights the list as you
know goes on and on so are you arguing
that the constitution needs to be
scrapped altogether
sure but i don't think that's going to
happen like
like if we could throw that out and
start over with a new document that was
more inclusive of everybody that was
written by everybody at no point have
black people brown people or women had a
say in actually writing the constitution
or the amendments to that constitution
if we could throw that out and have a
delegation of all americans to write a
new one i would be all for that that's
what they did in south africa you know
when they got when they got rid of
apartheid they didn't like tax
amendments onto their apartheid
constitution they threw the apartheid
constitution out and they started over
yeah i don't think that's going to
happen here um and so instead of that
what i'm really advocating for is that
we interpret our constitution so that it
so that we extend justice and fairness
and equality to all as opposed to
whatever the heck we do now
so he's in favor of just getting rid of
the constitution and uh writing
something else and
i am not in favor of that i don't agree
with that but i i am quite happy to hear
i would prefer that though that people
on the left make that argument and just
come out and say it
because one of the reasons why um our
debates never get anywhere is that
people aren't really being honest about
what they actually think
and pretty much every debate is had in
bad faith
and that's especially the case when we
start talking about constitutional
issues
where both sides including the left you
know usually pretend that what they
really care about is protecting the
constitution and all that it's of course
completely bogus
yeah you want to you want to rip up the
the constitution you want to burn it
throw it in the incinerator that's
that's very clear because everything
about our country and its history you
hate everything
come out and say it it's it's already
obvious but the more you say it i think
the better
um all right let's go here so there was
a
a protest a pro-mask protest in new york
city these are people that gathered
to protest in favor of masking and let's
let's check in with that
that is so sad i think i prefer the
screaming satanic ones over that
uh this this somehow is
an even more pathetic display
and what are they protesting for exactly
you know they're they're
all their signs and everything said
masking masking for all
we'll go ahead and ask no one's stopping
you
there there are no laws being put in
place especially not in new york city
saying that you can't wear the mask
outlawing it
now if it were up to me i would probably
put that law in place
i think actually there should be laws
um against masking not just taking the
mandates away but putting a mandate in
the other direction
that you can't just walk around in a
mask all the time unless you have a real
reason and one of the reasons for a law
like that by the way is um
it would put us it would put a stop to a
lot of the looting that we're seeing
because before everyone lost their mind
with mines with kovid it was generally
understood that you can't have a bunch
of people going into stores and
establishments covering their faces
when people walk around in anonymity
every single day bad things happen
but that's that that's not happening
especially not happening in new york so
what are they protesting for they can
still wear the mask
well because it's not good enough for
them to wear it they need everyone so
they're protesting asking for a mandate
from the government
asking for the government to mandate
them to do the thing they're already
doing anyway
because it's not about them it's about
you they also want to control what you
do
all right finally want to play this
before we get to the comment section a
mom on um tick tock is getting ready to
deliver her baby she's not going to
deliver the baby on tick tock at least i
hope not but you never know anymore and
she's come up with a
written list of rules
uh
about the birth and basically governing
the way that her friends and family can
behave and what they can do it's pretty
extensive we can't play the entire thing
it goes on for like three minutes so
she's listing like 50 rules but let's
let's play some of this
my husband and i made a list of
guidelines for our friends and family
for when i go into labor and we have our
first daughter our first baby is due
march 14th i'm currently 34 weeks
pregnant so we um being first-time
parents and being a little extra decided
to come up with this list called 2319
for people to kind of know what our
expectations are and what we're
comfortable with so the first guideline
is that if we tell you i'm in labor
don't announce baby's arrival don't post
that i'm in labor until i've posted i
don't know if i'm going to want to post
immediately that she's here or give it a
whole week
so we're just asking that people don't
do that
also please don't inform other people
unless we ask you to because we don't
want to be bombarded with texts
number two kind of goes off of that when
we tell you that we're in labor we will
be sending updates but we're going to be
sending updates that we're comfortable
with and
on our schedule we won't be responding
to requests for update updates outside
of that so that way my husband doesn't
have to juggle 30 people texting him
okay hey what's the latest news or
whatever
number three
is pretty simple don't post pictures of
baby
until we do and please ask permission
okay
we can stop that so those are all her
rules for uh for when she gives birth
you know we've had four kids we didn't
post any rules at all uh we didn't think
to do that but it's part of this trend
now with um
you know people
like
they they do something
that billions of other people have
already done in history but now when
they do it
in her mind
right this is the first significant
birth that's ever happened on earth well
the second because the first was her own
and um and now and now this
uh billions of people have gone through
this have given birth have been born
they need any rules didn't need to make
a big huge
show out of it
but no this is different because it's
her now
it's the same thing it's why people you
know
she i guarantee she was the bridezilla
when she got married assuming she is
married which maybe i can't assume that
um i think she did say husband so same
deal there i'm sure can you imagine if
this is if this is the rule she's
putting in place now she's acting when
she gives birth
can you imagine what she put her friends
and family through when she got married
because that's the other thing that
people you know they get married and
many people and getting married is a
wonderful thing and i wish it happened
more often in fact there should be more
marriages but but still you're doing
something that billions of people have
already done but now that you're doing
it you think it needs to be you need to
be treated like royalty and you can pass
all these rules down and treat everybody
around you like garbage
and yet she still has friends and family
at the end of that which is uh which is
maybe the most impressive thing at all
of all let's get now to the comment
section
[Music]
all right we will tepidly dip into some
of these video comments dailywire.com
sweet baby comments i think i'm gonna
stop giving out that url actually
let's go to clip
13.
you might get a kick out of it
of course
you like it
no i think it's
don't show it to the camera
spg for life
and she threw it
you know i i don't know if this is a
well so this is a a man giving a gift to
the woman in his life i don't know if
they're married or not
and she he he gave her the sweet baby
t-shirt
um
which is uh not only a beautiful gift
also kind of frankly kind of an
expensive gift as well
and uh and she she throws it aside look
i i just said i i think marriage is a
wonderful thing more people should get
married
um
i would never recommend
divorce
but there are exceptions to every rule
that's all i'll say let's go to clip 16.
hey i'm really disappointed
in the the horrible treatment of
producer mckenna
and dear dear uncle murray
i am proposing
that
we say sweet mckenna for life
until you have something nice to say
about her and uncle murray
uncle murray has a great voice he should
be
um
voicing
the daily wires movies or you know
books whatever he's got a great voice i
love listening he's funny mckenna was
right in picking that clip
and um you were of course wrong so
sweet mckenna for life until you have
something nice to say about those two
okay i'm banning the video comments from
the show i think we
we tried it it's just not working out
and before you def don't okay you're
trying to put this guy up on the screen
don't put it he's not he's not that's
not happening
uncle murray
uh
no we're not putting him up before you
go defending mckenna i should let you
know something else um adding insult to
injury to you know to my injury the
other this is true like two days ago
in fact we were at we were doing the
backstage and it was during
the state of the union and i asked
mckenna she was there i said can you go
run and get me some water because i'm on
camera here okay i'm the talent and i
need some water so i can continue to
speak and and relay all my wisdom to the
masses
and then she told me that she can't go
get me a water
because she was in a cast and she had
just
severely sprained her ankle
these are the kind of excuses that i
have to deal with
all the time
all right
let's see here's some good news
greatness says hey matt sweet baby gang
is spreading rapidly i'm a 14 year old
and i absolutely love your podcast at my
dodgeball tournament i convinced my team
to be named sweet baby gang and we got
third place out of six teams so well
each team has six players glad to
represent sbg for life
that's
that that's good news i mean third place
out of you still beat three other teams
so i'll give you credit for that um
and uh tevin says was that a teacher
clapping along with those animals yeah i
said i got that comment a lot um after
the after the show yesterday we played
the footage of uh what happened at the
jeff younger event and they were you
know cussing him out and screaming at
him and chanting you know whatever they
were chanting
and you could see an adult standing up
there and clapping along a lot of people
thought oh is that is that a teacher a
professor clapping along with the um
with the chanting animals and no that
was jeff younger himself who was like
chanting along with
his own with he was like going along
with the people jeering him and and
chanting along with it
um
which is not the best way to respond in
a situation like that
um
but then again i mean you have to keep
in mind with especially with jeff
younger
is that
you know he it doesn't seem to me that
this is a guy who ever wanted to be a
public figure
he just
didn't want his son
to be castrated he didn't want his son
to be raised as a girl
and
he's had no choice but to take it you
know he tried to stop it in court that
didn't work
now he's running for office to try to
stop it
now i don't know anything really about
jeff younger
but um
this is a this is a father at least who
cares about protecting his son and will
do anything to make it happen um even
putting himself in a position like that
so a lot of respect for that i have some
exciting news for you the delhi wire is
adding even more content to your queue
and we can't wait to share it with you
so mark your calendars for march 10th
the premiere of our latest film the
hyperions will happen it's not woke it
doesn't have some underlying political
message it's just an excellent film it's
entertaining because when it comes to
entertainment that's really all that
matters uh see for yourself check out
the trailer good day hyperion club
members
[Music]
[Applause]
we've come for one thing
our titan badges this titan badge can
grant an individual superhuman power
perhaps it's time for someone else to
take on the responsibility
on my way
[Music]
[Applause]
she's trying to destroy me
hyperion's is a dysfunctional family
film with throwback vibes and it's 100
worth the stream we'll be streaming the
film once uh once on march 10th for all
of youtube to see is the last time we'll
be premiering a movie on youtube so be
sure to head on over to the daily wire
youtube channel set a reminder for the
live showing but after that you've got
to be a member to get in on the action
so head to dailywire.com subscribe so
you don't miss any more of um all of the
content that we have coming up also when
everyone else is kneeling some men have
the courage to stand alone one of them
is nba star jonathan isaac who despite
facing heavy criticism from the media
for his views on social issues and
vaccines over the past few years still
stood strong which is why i'm extremely
excited to announce that he's decided to
write a book with the daily wire called
why i stand jonathan's book will be out
would be about the rise of his
basketball career his journey into faith
and his strength to stand alone in the
face of immense pressure the book is
available for pre-order now at amazon so
reserve your copy today
and finally to state the obvious every
social media platform is overrun with
insane leftist drivel littered with blue
hair tic toc social justice warriors
word vomiting their nonsensical
ideological framework all over your feed
that they don't even understand
themselves and that's and there's just
not that much content that caters to the
sane youth that is the same youth the
young up and coming conservatives who
will quite literally be running things
one day that's why our new show the
comment section aims to change that
featuring our newest addition to the
daily wire lineup of host brett cooper
the comment section is an irreverent
viral content and news review show that
offers an against the grain laid back
perspective on all of the insanity of
today and will even take you into one of
the scariest places the online world has
to offer the comment section believe me
i know the show is streaming now on
youtube for all to see
so make sure that you go to subscribe to
the comment section with brett cooper
and click the notification bell so you
don't miss it now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
so a few days ago was ash wednesday a
day of fasting sacrifice and repentance
leading into lent a liturgical season of
solemn and prayerful preparation before
the holy celebration of easter
ash wednesday is as you might expect
not quite as popular these days as what
comes before it which is fat tuesday or
mardi gras mardi gras which
traditionally was a time of feasting
before the period of fasting but in our
culture we prefer to take the feast
without the fast
you know fat tuesday leads to fat
wednesday followed by fat thursday
and even fatter friday and so on as
christianity declines in america so too
to our religious observances
as for that decline you know there are
many christians who mourn the fact that
our numbers are dwindling and they are
and fewer people are taking part in our
traditions
the rise in religiously unaffiliated and
atheist self-identifications
is often lamented by believers and i
lament it too
but i also much prefer
that unbelievers declare themselves
as such declare themselves unaffiliated
renounce their faith openly and align
themselves with some other belief system
i prefer that
than the other approach which is to
continue identifying themselves as
christians even while rejecting nearly
every essential aspect of christianity
in other words i'll take apostasy over
heresy any day of the week better to
renounce your faith and and leave
than remain in it destroying it from the
inside
but there are a lot of heretics in our
society today uh we have one in the
white house actually joe biden calls
himself a catholic a devout catholic in
fact
and yet his devotion to catholicism does
not include the fundamental moral
teachings of catholicism
he's devoted to everything but that
which is like saying you're totally
devoted to your wife except when you're
cheating on her that's the only thing
biden loves the church but rejects
nearly everything it says
just one example of many the church says
that abortion is murder and atrocity
an intrinsic moral evil
biden says that it's maternal health
care
and he was asked about this particular
this uh disconnect on wednesday right
after he emerged from church with the
ashes on his forehead for ash wednesday
and here's what he said
last night because i knew people wrote
me away
i didn't support
abortion speaking i tell you what
i don't want to get in a debate with you
on theology but you know well anyway
i'm not gonna i'm not i'm not gonna make
it i'm not gonna make a judgment for
other people
oh it's not for him to judge
now that answer is nonsense for many
reasons not least because biden clearly
loves nothing more than to judge people
he judges on vaccinated people parents
at school board meetings trump
supporters conservatives anyone who
disagrees with him about anything
anything
like any leftist he's constantly making
moral pronouncements and judgments
pretty much the only thing he will not
judge is the murder of infants
but but we can judge that and we should
because it is as the church says an
intrinsic moral evil
contrary to popular belief we as
christians are not we're not only
permitted to make judgments but we're
actually required to
so when you hear someone say christians
shouldn't judge that that's simply
someone who calls himself a christian
and there are many of these
but has never actually picked up the
bible and opened it
it would be you know of course we we are
supposed to make judgments
it would be rather difficult to apply
any of the moral teachings in the gospel
if we aren't allowed to make any moral
judgments to begin with
yeah this kind of confusion is common
now largely due to the work of heretics
like biden
speaking of heretics we go back to ash
wednesday
uh remember that ash wednesday is
supposed to be a time of repentance of
mourning for our sins of remembering as
we're reminded when the ashes are
applied that we are dust and to dust we
shall return
that's what ash wednesday has always
been but in recent years the heretics
have been making some slight alterations
to it this week across the country a
number of churches held services not for
regular old ash wednesday but for
glitter ash wednesday
glitter ash wednesday is ash wednesday
but with a little gay flair
one of these um demonic perversions of a
previously solomon sacred observance was
held at michigan state university and
there was a local fox reporter there who
interviewed a female pastor because of
course it's a female pastor
from an episcopal church because of
course
and here's how she explained it
so on campus canterbury msu which is the
the episcopal campus ministry um is
um once again
we did this right before covid
we again are giddy are offering glitter
ashes on campus
so this is a program that has come out
of a national organization called parody
that seeks
equality for lgbtq plus folks and
glitter ashes is a way to recognize the
ways in which the church has too often
failed to
recognize much less include lgbtq folks
and and so for the glitter ashes the the
ashes traditional ashes that we use the
same that we'll use
the rest of the day on ash wednesday get
mixed with a little bit of glitter as a
sign of reconciliation and love and
inclusion not just for lbgtq folks
certainly for that but also of course if
we include anyone we're widening the
circle for everyone
if you're someone who has felt excluded
from the church
maybe your home church or maybe the
church in general and
and that's painful for you and you're
looking for a way to acknowledge that to
acknowledge
maybe faith that you feel somewhat
exiled from this might be a way to do
that and and that would certainly be our
hope that that anyone who has felt like
the church has not made a place for them
that this is a sign that in fact there
is a place for you and if the church has
failed to say that it's the church is
failing not yours
so
glitter ash wednesday is just like ash
wednesday except the exact opposite of
it
at glitter ash wednesday rather than
being told that they are dust and to
dust they shall return observers are
told that they are special and wonderful
in every way rather than being called to
humility
they're called explicitly to pride
rather than recalling the sins they've
committed
they recall the alleged sins committed
against them
rather than focusing on christ they're
encouraged to focus on themselves
this is not christianity this is
satanism
it's the worship of self
which is what satanism is
so we see that although christianity may
be losing ground in the west
it's not really being replaced by
secularism irreligion is not taking the
place of religion
instead a new religion is gaining ground
we we are we are still
really a deeply religious culture as
we've always been
but it's the religion of the self
this religion makes its own supernatural
claims such as the claim that boys can
magically become girls
it has its own priests some of them
still masquerading as christian priests
it has its own observances
some of the some of them inversions of
christian observances
it has its own commandments
which are basically the ten commandments
flipped on their head
you are your own god there shall be no
god before you hate your father and
mother you shall steal you shall murder
especially your children you shall covet
and attempt to be coveted
these are the moral edicts of our
religions of our culture's dominant
religion
and the more it identifies itself as a
separate religion
rather than trying to remain
parasitically attached to christianity
the better
go ahead and have your glittered
observances smear glitter on your face
all you want while reflecting on how
special you think you are
just stop pretending that it has
anything to do with the christian faith
while you're doing it
and also of course we must say you're
canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great weekend godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pavovsky our
associate producer is mckenna waters the
show is edited by robbie dantzler our
audio is mixed by mike coromina and hair
and makeup is done by cherokee heart the
matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin